foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory and today we're going to
be unpacking one of the more mysterious
aspects of Harry Potter the department
of mysteries honing in further we're
going to be taking a look at the
peculiar workers of this department
Ministry employees known as the
unspeakables we'll also be looking at
later in the video all of the rooms
chambers that reside inside the
department of mysteries the ministry of
magic is the primary form of government
in the magical world at least in the UK
like a Michael government the ministry's
responsibilities are vast as they are
the primary body that attempts to
sustain Law and Order in the magical
world like any system of government in
an effort to cover as much ground as
possible the primary governmental body
is systematically divided to focus on
different sectors of The Wizarding World
these sectors or departments govern the
more common areas like the department of
magical law enforcement and the
department of magical Transportation but
there are also other departments
reserved for Less obvious Pursuits and Q
level 9 the department of mysteries the
department of mysteries is responsible
for studying the mysteries of the
Wizarding World Mysteries associated
with love space thought time death and
other things basically anything that is
unknown anything pertaining to this
department is highly confidential and
those who work in this department are
referred to as unspeakables the
divisions of this department are broken
up by area of study and includes the
following the brain room the Hall of
Prophecy the death chamber the love
chamber the space chamber and the time
room these rooms are accessed via the
room of doors a large circular room
where everything is black what's
particularly curious or dare I say
mysterious about the department of
Mysteries is that it actually preceded
the existence of the ministry itself the
ministry was established in 1707 and the
department of mysteries had activity as
early as 1672. the name checks out and
while we're given a cursory introduction
to the department and even spent some
time there in both the books and films
there's still so much to unpack with
regards to this mysterious Department
who are the people that work there where
do they come from are they Hogwarts
graduates are they regular witches and
wizards I'm going to start with what we
do know and go from there the first
thing that I want to address is that the
reason so little is known about these
enigmatic figures is that they are
strictly forbidden from discussing their
line of work even with the other
Ministry members outside of their
department when a new employee is
brought on at the department of
mysteries they must take a vow where
they reinforce under oath that their job
is strictly offline from the general
public this is how they got the name the
unspeakables in the first place Demi all
this seems a bit cliche especially for a
department that supposedly deals with
the most incomprehensible elements of
the universe but we'll leave that alone
I also can't help but wonder why the
department wouldn't use fidelius charms
to ensure that all of the information
inside of the department is kept hidden
for those unaware the fidelius charm is
an incredibly powerful piece of magic
that conceals a secret inside of a
chosen secret Keeper's Soul this would
have been easy to implement and would
have served as a very effective
additional Safeguard which seems sort of
worth it if we consider that this
department studies the underlying
mysteries of Life Death love and the
universe but then again the ministry of
magic is a bit of a bureaucratic mess
okay so the unspeakables are Ministry
workers who have promised not to tell
anyone about their line of work what
else do we know about them the next
thing I want to point out is that the
unspeakables or most of them anyway are
most likely humanoid witches and wizards
I say this because we do actually know
the identity of a few of them
these witches Wizards include Saul
Croaker an unspeakable who'd worked at
the department of mysteries for his
entire life Broderick bode an
unspeakable who notably became targeted
by the Death Eaters while Voldemort
search for the prophecy in the Hall of
prophecies Lavina monk Stanley a witch
and unspeakable credited with the
creation of both the wand lighting charm
lumos and wand extinguishing charm Knox
and lastly but perhaps most notably
Augustus Rookwood an unspeakable turned
Death Eater Voldemort spy that caused
all sorts of problems with his
connections inside of the ministry I
think it would be fair to say that of
all the ministry of magic workers the
unspeakables were the most competent and
I say this because the issues that they
dealt with were the most complex their
primary responsibilities were studying
time in the time room the same place
where time Turners were kept and later
destroyed studying death in the death
chamber the infamous chamber housing The
Veil The claimed Sirius Black's life
organizing prophecies in the Hall of
prophecies tending to the swimming
brains in the brain room researching the
solar system in the space room and
finally studying love in the love
chamber love is of particular importance
in Harry Potter as it is one of the key
thematic elements in the series as well
as one of the most powerful forms of
magic remember Lily's loving sacrifice
that single spell protected Harry for
most of his life it contains a force
that is at once more wonderful and more
terrible than death than human
intelligence than the forces of nature
it is also perhaps the most mysterious
of the many subjects for study that
reside there it is the power held within
that room that you possess in such
quantities and which Voldemort has not
at all Dumbledore is also on the record
as having stated that the love chamber
was locked at all times
the reason for this well aside from love
being incredibly powerful it's also
rumored that the love chamber houses an
entire Fountain of amortencia the Love
Potion given that Voldemort himself was
conceived out of a love potion I don't
think we want people meddling around in
there fired the gas I'd wager that this
is where the powerful potion was first
created and much like the love potion
and mortencia originated in the love
chamber the tricky little device known
as the time Turner was created in the
time room a room adorned with clocks and
a bell jar where a bird hatches lives
and dies on a loop the department of
mystery's first experimented with time
travel back in the 19th century and it
was then that elwaz Min tumble and
unspeakable at that time managed to
violate a plethora of laws what's more
it was Min tumble's experimentation with
time that sealed her fate all attempts
to travel back further than a few hours
have resulted in catastrophic harm to
the witch or wizard involved it was not
realized for many years why Time
Travelers over great distances never
survived their Journeys all such
experiments have been abandoned since
1899 when elwaz Min tumble became
trapped for a period of five days in the
year 1402 now we understand that her
body had aged five centuries in its
return to the present and irreparably
damaged she died in Saint Margaret's
Hospital for Magical maladies and
injuries shortly after we managed to
retrieve her what is more her five days
in the distant past caused Great
disturbance to the life Paths of all
those she met changing the course of
their lives so dramatically that no
fewer than 25 of their descendants
vanished in the present having been
unborn perhaps before messing with time
they should have spent more time in the
brain room a long rectangular room lit
by low hanging lamps the highlight of
which tank of brains swimming in a Green
Solution apparently the oddly aggressive
brains kept inside of the chamber were
used to study Thoughts with the tendrils
representing physical manifestations of
thoughts but to me this raises a few
questions where on Earth did these
brains come from were they created or
brought in why are they so angry what
kind of thoughts are the unspeakables
provoking
something worthy of note is that otolene
gamble who served as head of the
ministry from 1827 to 1835 was known to
have established committees to
investigate muggle brain power this was
prompted by the rise of the British
Empire which alerted the magical world
to the fact that muggle IQs may have
been higher than they initially thought
I wonder if those were muggle brains all
in all a very unusual room next up the
death chamber the death chamber is
fortunately one of the few rooms from
the Department we get to experience on
the Silver Screen making its way into
the movies in the Order of the Phoenix
just like love death plays a huge role
in Harry Potter and pops up all over the
place it's also massively complex think
about it we've got horcruxes ties to the
Mortal realm ghosts Spirits with
unfinished business and even
Resurrection Stones rocks that can bring
back shades of the dead but perhaps even
more complicated than those three put
together is the centerpiece of the death
chamber The Veil The massive ancient
stone Archway which stand in the center
of the death chamber acts as a sort of
portal between the lands of the living
and the dead it is believed that those
who step through the veil or fall
through become trapped in the world of
death
those who stand close enough and have
belief in the afterlife are also able to
hear faint whisperings that appear to
come from the of the side whatever you
believe this is one of the most
interesting parts of the entire
department next up the space chamber
where the Unspeakable studied any and
all aspects pertaining to the planets
and the universe a dark room full of
planets floating in mid-air while the
relationship between space and Magic is
unclear there is likely a correlation as
its importance is reinforced by the
centaurs of the Forbidden Forest who
once remarked that the planet Mars was
bright there isn't much more information
on this department but I guess that's
why it's inside the department of
mysteries what do you guys think last up
we have the Hall of Prophecy a large
hole that plays a major role in the
Harry Potter story and houses well
prophecies predictions made by Sears
which are then recorded in spheres
though the unspeakables have authority
of this chamber it should be mentioned
that prophecies can only be removed by
those about whom they are made not even
the unspeakables can access these
prophecies and if they tried they would
be struck by the powerful defensive
spells in place that protect them why
these prophecies are stored kept hidden
away and entirely unavailable to the
people involved with said prophecies is
beyond me but who am I to question the
confusing bureaucracy that is the
ministry of magic well we don't have any
information on how employees are
recruited for this vital Department I'm
willing to bet that only the top witches
and wizards from their respective
academic institutions are chosen but
while intelligence is pivotal I also
think the role requires a particular
type of person to give you an idea
Broderick Bode is described as being a
sallow skinned wizard with a very
mournful face that spoke with a
sepulchral type of voice he also had an
unfaltering gaze that made everyone
comfortable
come to think of it Snape probably would
have made a perfect unspeakable did I
miss anything that we know about the
unspeakables or about the department of
mysteries if so be sure to leave your
comments and any video suggestions you
may have down below until next time
remember it is the unknown We Fear when
we look upon death and darkness nothing
more